pour sensibiliser une partie de ses
agents le conseil général a mis en place
une formation à l'éco-conduite
cette formation a pour but d'informer
les usagers sur leur façon de conduire
mais également de proposer des solutions
en donnant des astuces et des méthodes
pour conduire avec le moins d'impact
possible sur notre environnement
le département a donc proposé cette
formation aux agents et chauffeurs qui
travaillent au sein même du conseil
général yves raclin a bénéficié de cette
formation et a dû revoir sa façon
d'utiliser son véhicule
beaucoup d'employeurs pour le fait de
conduire comme un acquis et oublient que
cela reste un privilège conduire devient
une habitude pas la routine s'installe à
la londe machinalement prend le volant
on quitte chez soi on va vers l'est vers
le son lieu de travail
on a souvent la tête dans l'est avec le
travail et pas forcément avec la la
situation laisse âgées donc on prend des
habitudes qui à mon sens c'est peut-être
négatif pour le chauffeur voilà donc
machinalement ont enclenché vitesse dont
le contrat dont seraient poursuit le fut
le véhicule car plus on se dit souvent
si on a des remarques
j'ai pu tout autant que permis est-ce
que que vous que voulez vous que je dise
de plus un jour ces conduits il est vrai
aussi que cette formation m'a beaucoup
aidé c'est vrai qu'on prend on a
tendance à prendre de mauvaises
habitudes comme je le disais donc de la
routine n'est par contre ça m'a aidé à
une conduite sûre ça m'a aidé une
conduite économique et responsable vis à
vis des usagers et d'environnement ça
m'a aidé à nathan pratique des
techniques simples de conduite tout
simplement conduire mon véhicule a cette
capacité de fonctionnement optimal de
manière à économiser du carburant ce qui
n'est pas négligeable aujourd'hui avec
nos coûts de deux prix de l'essence
cette formation m'a appris aussi dont la
pratique de l'éco conduite
les passes par cinq failles
fondamentales première règle changer les
rapports à bas régime moteur
deuxième règle maintenir une détestable
anciennes règles vous utilisez un régime
moteur de plus bas possible quatrième
règles anticipé le ralentissement du
trafic et 5ème règles entreprenez avons
vécu grâce à cette formation
ivins fait maintenant bien plus
attention à sa manière de conduire car
il est conscient de son impact sur
l'environnement
il gère son véhicule différemment depuis
cette formation le conseil général a
constaté de gros changements sur les
consommations de carburant
c'est une preuve qu avoir une conduite
écologique c'est avoir une conduite
économique
la réunion tout entière est concernée
par le développement durable
l'application et l'investissement du
conseil général dans ce domaine ont été
reconnu au niveau national la
collectivité représentait quand la
présidente nassimah dindar ainsi reçu la
récompense les rubans du développement
durable dans la période 2012 2014
l'éco conduite n'est qu'un des aspects
de cette implication quotidienne que
nous devons tous mettre en pratique pour
léguer à nos enfants les plus belles des
réunions aussi